knock knock who's there who there me and
this can broccoli that I'm about to make
you eat No
[Music]
I hate broccoli I hate everything about
broccoli I hate broccoli my parents had
to serve me broccoli in a bunch of
different ways and at the end of the day
as soon as they left the room I would
often just throw it away whenever I go
out to eat with friends and I get
broccoli on my dish I always give it
away to somebody else I went on a date
where a guy told me he was gonna cook me
dinner and it was a nice steak which I
loved and then a huge side of broccoli
which I hate do I eat the broccoli and
hope I don't throw up or do I not eat
the broccoli and then I'm the 22 year
old who still won't eat her vegetables
so I ended up just pushing it around my
plate never saw him again so I just
think there's no way that anybody can
make me like broccoli
there is nothing any of these chefs can
do to get me to like broccoli it's been
tried it's not gonna happen I don't
think there is anything you could do to
make me like broccoli my name is Ross
Panetta currently the junior sous chef
over at pig and cow they're cooking
professionally for about three years now
I'm happy healthy latina aka chef Otte
aka the vegetable Slayer and I'm
bringing that plant-based natural
Caribbean flavor to all the cooking that
I do I think I've been cooking
professionally for about five years a
lot of the work that I do is actually
with children and so I'm constantly
having to hide and tuck vegetables and
blend them and deconstruct it and bring
it in some way I have to be a picky
eater since growing up I've got a lot of
allergies you kind of grow around it and
you learn how to suck the two things
with my experience with picky eaters
it's a little bit difficult sometimes
not gonna lie at the end of the day you
got to make everybody satisfied with
what you do and what you cook Oh y'all
picky eaters out there we try and meet
y'all come see us bring us our victim
rolling it down we're ready to make
believers we hear that you're one of
these people now that don't like luckily
why is that I don't like the taste I
don't like the smell I don't like the
texture I don't like the color I don't
like the gag reflex it gives me
okay I think it's the texture mixture
just like the little fuzzy bits on the
top of it for us we learned something
new today
I don't understand how you're supposed
to eat it it confuses me do I eat the
top do I eat the bottom don't use it all
at the same time our taste buds like
change our palates develop and change as
we get older I think you have this like
scar with broccoli but you may not you
may not have lots of scars emotional
scars hmm I think the only times I've
ever been presented with broccoli it's
just been steamed and it's just that
well this is what I'm always talking
about it's not that people don't like
vegetables is that they don't do the
same things to vegetables that they do
let's say to like proteins season it put
sauce is on what are kind of things you
do like to eat spicy food like savory
things are your basis okay like savory
like spicy I dance when I'm happy yeah
so like you're saying things that I like
so like savory spicy they're gonna be in
the situation ship with broccoli okay
today not a relationship just a
situation [ __ ] one nice them odds be
ever in your favor
I think they're gonna go from hating
broccoli to Elliot mildly liking it or
possibly loving it who knows what is
going to happen I cannot wait to mix in
Dominican and Caribbean flavors into
vegetables I decided to go to chains on
this broccoli I'm gonna make it two ways
and I'm gonna deconstruct it first I'm
gonna bring it into a broccoli corn and
black-eyed pea fritter and then I'm
going to do a charred broccoli
chimichurri sauce on the bottom I don't
think that they're expecting some heat
some spice some savoriness I'm bringing
sweet corn into my fritters to balance
out the broccoli taste but my
chimichurri has sofrito in it which is a
Dominican Caribbean green spice blend so
that's my kind of different little take
on it a little trick I must see you you
the more to be making
is a corn aioli with a chimichurri
mixing people are always like scared
about the flavor of broccoli the char
adds flavor and disguises up broccoli if
you like barbecue like anything charred
you know I think that introducing the
corn with the chimichurri will make it
over the top so much broccoli Matt
broccoli right Matt broccoli done they
said they liked spice they like herb
enos they're like brightness so I got
jalapeno to get all up in your face I
got some chopped cilantro for the
Urbanus I'm coming back with the zester
so we've got some broccoli corn fritters
here over a charred broccoli sofrito
chimichurri with jalapeno fresh cilantro
and lemon zest garnish we came to slay
the broccoli game so finally finished my
plate what we have here is a charred
broccoli charred corn aioli with sirloin
and a table rock a chimichurri on top
[Music]
ready okay yeah it's not that stronger
brothy taste it all there's a lot going
on yeah
if it were not for the color I wouldn't
know that there was any like green
veggies in here I think that slight edge
is gonna go to the veggie dish I like
the bass spicy jalapeno is going on this
is really hard just like both of them
were really good and they were both
super flavorful thought it was
interesting that both dishes also had
corn I think the corn masa the broccoli
tastes really well but I feel like I
prefer the appetizer dish or the steak
dish appetizer dish was had so many
different flavors and when I was biting
into it and I was thinking about how
many vegetables were in it I was just
like so shocked and steak dish was also
great the fact that it had like
vegetables and broccoli on it but I
liked the appetizer dish dare I say do
we have some broccoli lovers a little
bit about if it was did you love the
broccoli today I'm not a broccoli lover
per se but I'm a believer now that you
can make broccoli taste good if you have
some bomb-ass professional chefs prepare
it for you my mom would be smiling
really proudly right now maybe crying so
do you think we slayed this challenge
teamwork make the dream work baby lit
[Music]